there has been a major major defeat for
the corporate Democratic establishment
that I want to tell you about
Congressman Joe Crowley is a high
ranking Democrat in the House of
Representatives chair of the house
Democratic caucus considered a contender
second in line for Speaker of the House
if Democrats were to take over the House
of Representatives in November is that
gonna happen well anyway we'll discuss
that later but potentially a guy who
would be in line for the speakership he
has been defeated in the Democratic
primary in New York's 14th district by
twenty eight-year-old Democratic
Socialist Alexandria
Acacio Cortez Crowley out fundraised
Acacio Cortes by a 10 to 1 margin and
yet still lost to her by roughly 15
percentage points 57 to 42 Crowley
clearly the guy running to the right
Acacio Cortes ran quite a bit to the
left of Crowley ran on a Federal jobs
guarantee ran on Medicare for all also
ran on the abolition of I switch item I
think is totally unprecedented and sent
a surrogate and I mean that just looks
so stunningly horrible the absence by
Crowley from that debate was called
disrespectful by Acacio Cortes Donald
Trump reacting to this win by Alexandria
kaznia Cortes making it all about him
Trump tweeting this morning Wow big
Trump hater Congressman Joe Crowley who
many expected was going to take Nancy
Pelosi's place just lost his primary
election in other words he's out that is
a big one that nobody saw happening
perhaps he should have been nicer and
more respectful to his president this
could be one of the dumbest political
analyses of the last decade can you
imagine people to the left of Joe
Crowley were mad that Crowley criticized
Trump so they voted in someone
even more progressive to send a signal
that it's not okay to criticize Donald
Trump you've got to be truly dumb or
just have total delusions of grandeur to
believe something like that both of
which probably apply to Donald Trump
but Trump analysis aside this is one of
the major upsets of the Trump era and
even some of the defeats we've seen of
Republicans by Democrats since November
of 2016 don't have the same degree of
sort of fighting incumbency that this
victory has because in the 14th district
Crowley was a big-time establishment
Democrat again a high ranking second in
line for Speaker of the House 10
consecutive elections for Crowley
without a serious challenger and he had
one here and he lost and there is a
dynamic that's developing in the wake of
Alexandria Acacio cortezes win which is
that there are some people on the right
saying this isn't a big win for
Democrats this is just identity politics
and the argument that the right is
making is listen Alexandria Acacio
Cortes is latina and she won in a highly
Latino area so it's just the left voting
on race and ethnicity and that's it and
you can try to make that case but this
was an extremely progressive candidate
compared to Crowley if she had been the
same identity right a Latina woman but
running to the right of Crowley is she
still gonna win I don't think so I
actually think that there's always you
can't eliminate the fact that people
have identities but the idea that her
election went the way it went totally
irrespective of the political positions
that she took I think is a a claim that
you can't actually defend with facts
yeah there's no way really to run to the
right of Joe Crowley
Republican primary I mean maybe you can
make the case that a Hispanic Republican
could win there but I don't think you
can not New York I don't think so and if
you look online you'll see not only
right-wing criticism of what it means
that Democrats are defeating other
Democrats but you've got the troll BOTS
in full force if you look at red
or Talking Points Memo any websites that
allow comments on articles related to
this election you will see a flood of
easily identifiable Russian troll saying
uh-oh this is a bad sign for Democrats
because you've got a Latina progressive
who defeated a white guy and it's just
destructive identity politics and of
course the truth is this could be good
for Democrats or it could be not good
for Democrats I tend to believe that
having elected officials who are more in
line with the politics of their
constituents is a good thing for too
long in the United States we've seen our
representatives be to the right of where
their constituents are and in general
we've seen House and Senate elected
officials be to the right of where the
American people are on average when it
comes to so many political issues don't
fall for the idea that this is in
principle bad because it's in fighting
primaries are primaries this is one of
the main foundations of the democratic
process and it actually shows you Pat
how scared they are that they have to
reframe primaries as Democratic
infighting that's bad no this is called
the democratic process and this is how
it works
yeah Republicans primary all the time
think back to 2010 during the Tea Party
era yep and look at where they are now
they have control of both houses they
have the presidency I mean their 2016
election run started with 17 candidates
and they won the whole thing and there
are major lessons here the the lesson
isn't that primaries are bad that's not
one of the lessons but one great lesson
is money usually wins but it doesn't
always win in this case Crowley out
fundraise ten to one but lost that's
good news even if anecdotally number two
this sort of establishment arrogance can
be lethal and this time it was lethal
for Crowley and lastly there is anger
with the Democratic establishment that
is coming from the more progressive wing
of the Democratic Party we knew that but
what we learn in this election is that
it can actually have an impact and here
the Democratic anger against the
Democratic establishment actually led to
a significant defeat for an
establishment Democrat last thing I
hope I hope that if ultimately
Alexandria Acacio Cortez wins in
November that she will make the
environmental issues a priority that she
will make health care a priority that
she will make the economy a priority I'm
concerned about making the abolition of
ice a priority mostly because I think it
would be an exercise in futility I don't
think that that's actually a good way to
invest time but we will ultimately see
what her general election campaign
shapes up to be send me your thoughts
about what these results mean I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman and the show is on
Twitter at David Pakman show